Wow how're you doing
that was powerful we were watching
backstage oh how amazing to witness
those are inspiring moments again from
David's films
well how about you and I speak about the
David day we know but the families he
builds and the process he uses to create
his films films from the mind of a
modern Renaissance man
the experience of seeing those films is
unforgettable they bring up these
extraordinary feelings who doesn't
remember the first time they saw a David
Lynch movie have you you think that's
incredible imagine the first time you
get to meet David Lynch it was actually
the luckiest day in my life
we met and I think he decided upon
meeting that I was gonna play the role
of Paul in dune and that was it simple
and my first meeting with David he cast
me at age 17 in blue velvet what you
were 17 yes Kyle appeared that's legal
anyway the three of us met oh very very
fancy Hollywood lunch yes siree
I'll never forget it Bob's Big Boy
and David sat there watching us well we
talked about our lines and our roles we
might play I remember well he was
doodling cartoons and ketchup with his
silverware mm-hmm never forget he had
that huge knowing smile on his face
because well we didn't have any idea but
he was creating a family right there
you became kale yes I did and you became
the tidbit right his nicknames for us
are stuck as we shared the privilege of
working with him are in
haier adult lives I'll never forget our
first work together on blue velvet
either my first workday as I recall with
you both on a David Lynch movie I hold
that memory forever it was a night shoot
right and we were on this beautiful
Street in the middle of the night in
this small sleepy town and David had
Shostakovich blaring through speakers
yeah yeah it was it was incredible you
knew you had walked into a world like no
other it was magic you came out of the
darkness toward me and stepped into the
light and you did the chicken walk yes I
did
he's doing it again David I think we
invented on the spot he not only gives
us bold and bound realist opportunities
as actors to enter his worlds but he has
asked many of us to create radically new
characters never concerned that we would
be identified with previous work we'd
done with him
he's even allowed us to literally play
several characters in the same movie I
got to do that in Twin Peaks and you did
an Inland Empire true I mean it's lets
me work freeing or radical than being on
the set for example of Inland Empire
sometimes when literally the set
consisted of David and myself and I
remember at one point you handing me a
screwdriver and saying remember you've
done something haunting but you don't
know how you got here and I said okay
but am I Nicki Grace at this point or
Susan blue or those other two characters
I think that are also me and you said
with the biggest smile on your face stop
asking so many questions did bet just go
we're David all the rules are thrown out
every actor and every crafts person
involved gets to redefine the rules make
new ones altogether
there's something about David and his
absolute belief and what an actor brings
to the role that brings out the very
best in all of us everyone who works
alongside David feels that electricity
it's his enthusiasm and passion that he
brings to set that infuses you with that
sense that you're doing what you were
always meant to mm-hmm and that's that's
really all any artist desires to be able
to work alongside other creative people
towards an end result that is fulfilling
and can be shared by and also move
others and as part of David's creative
crew and family we also get to spend a
lot of time visiting with David at his
home both now together and separately
hanging out what David means drinking
coffee of course these are teens has
some time at the infinity checking out
his new table saw having a sandwich
listening to a piece of music he's just
recorded in his studio or seeing him
knee-deep in tempera paint there is a
palpable hum of inventiveness and
imagination and for David the same level
of excitement goes into making a perfect
sandwich as it does for dreaming up a
scene for a film not a big distinction
or greater or lesser appreciation and
what sets David apart as an artist as he
takes that level of excitement and
uniquely dives into inventing every
aspect of the filmmaking process that's
why most days when you walk onto set you
will find David painting a wall hand
making your prop while also setting up a
shot and seamlessly giving you the
generous time in the world that you need
no matter what your role is in that
filmmaking process over the years
literally every filmmaker we ever worked
with has wanted to know what's it like
to work with David because many times it
was his influence that drew them into
filmmaking in the first place so true
and in fact you
who you are several of them are in this
room right now and it's incredible to
get to share David and all our
experiences with him with everyone else
and one of the amazing experiences that
I have had this year when talking with
the fellow Academy governors which I'm
privileged to be one I got to listen to
artists from all the branches sitting in
this room tonight
describing David as a master influencer
for them which is it's so meaningful
because this is what this night is about
when we have these discussions who we
have the privilege of honoring composers
sound mixers casting directors editors
animators David has truly touched all
the crafts of filmmaking you were also
inspired by his commitment to the idea
he says ideas are like fish if you want
to catch little fish you can stay in the
shallow water but if you want to catch
the big fish you've got to go deeper
down deep the fish are more powerful and
more pure they're huge and abstract and
very beautiful and what a privilege to
get to be part of that with you
so today there are many siblings in the
Lynch extended family a family that
respects him for his artistry and
admires him for his willingness to March
to his own drummer whether in making art
or in his commitment to the David Lynch
foundation which ensures that any child
anywhere in the world who wants to learn
to meditate can do so
David is a man who dares to invent and
to create and challenge himself with
every single new day a director a
painter a composer a photographer a
writer a cartoonist a prop maker sound
designer an editor a meditator an actor
an art director and animator a visionary
and yes Kael yes a true renaissance man
so on behalf of me and the tidbit of all
who have worked with you David and all
who love you and we do we do so much it
is our honor to present you David our
mentor and our best buddy with the Oscar
[Applause]